yes ah my name's Tony Manso I'm the
assessment accommodation lead team
bridging next to Council
I managed temporary accommodation and
stature to homeless assessments across
both local authority districts
traditionally and historically in team
bridge emergency accommodation provision
was provided through Bed and Breakfast
because we didn't have anything else
available that's kind of unsuitable in
terms of the lack of facilities for
clients placed there and also put a
significant financial burden on the
local authority because we weren't able
to gain full housing benefits subsidy
for those placements so alternative
provision was sought and we converted
this former GP surgery back in 2015 in
order to provide a solution that
provided bespoke support for clients and
also kind of value for money for the
local authority my name is Phil Murphy
I'm a project worker and sometimes I sit
in Albany house here and help the people
that find themselves here quite a lot of
the times its financial based helping
people with their benefits and taking
them to assessments for a SI and pip
also try and get them food packs and any
sort of emotional support that they they
sometimes may need because they're very
vulnerable when they come in here the
key advice really is to approach your
local authority at the earliest
opportunity if you think that you're
going to be homeless or threatened with
homelessness or you have any issues
which are compromising your tenancy or
security of tenure because although
we're very proud of the work that we do
here at Albany House ideally we don't
want to be placing people into emergency
accommodation we want to be preventing
or relieving homelessness at the
earliest opportunity I was lucky enough
to have a housing officer on my side
when I knew about it so when satine
bridge and they took me through the
steps of the homeless application then
that has to be assessed through
everything and then they eventually come
to it
whether they can home you or whether
it's your own fault
basically and they can't help you
sanctuary housing a quite communicative
they feel like they help you look for
private rented as well as help setting
you up I'm doing
Devon home Joyce Gary frontier District
Council is very supportive if you need
to get a life there's a problem or
anything to contact him I've had an
issue of out of hours and I rang the
out-of-hours number and that got dealt
with straightaway within a couple of
hours I've got two children and I
thought that the first thing that
happened is I had end up with with
social services or something like that
on my back because of this position but
they actually it's not they're not there
for that reason they're not involved
they're just so it's you know it's okay
it's not scary it is scary but it's not
a horrible so it will get better